you see here okay today we're switching
gears a little bit moving into out of
astrophysics and into fusion material
science with light sources biology with
light sources and winding up with talk
on a cheapy and the future of quantum
computing to kick us off we have John
Woo who is going to be telling us about
real-time detection and tracking in
fusion plasmas so please take away
thanks thanks Peter um so my name is
John Woo from Lawrence Berkeley National
Lab this application is about fusion
plasma but I'm personally a computer
scientists not a physicist so I will be
you know talking more about the computer
science part but I will talk about the
physics just just a little bit so here's
our line I'm going to start with a
summary a short version of the talk
effectively and we'll touch on a few
different applications in addition to
this particular fusion example then I'm
going to mention the data and process
management work that we actually do that
make this process work and then I'm
going to talk about the future
extraction algorithms that involves a
couple interesting tidbit and then I'm
going to talk about the fusion
application a little bit more so it's
going back to the fusion example so this
this work was funded and their project
called IC IC e at just sounds Co right
so the the vision here is to enable
real-time collaborative decision-making
so many you know this is a University of
campus many times for large experiment
like LHC or this fusion reactor this is
actually K star at Taichung South Korea
so it's a for large collaboration like
this open you know we send some young
folks graduate student out postdoc there
and when they run the device they often
ask for advices from more senior
participant and this is where
collaboration comes in in this
particular case you know there are
someone actually go there push the
button set there set the physical
parameters for the experiment okay so
the idea is to you know to make those
type of collaborations easy to do and so
listen this repeat some of the things I
have said already know near real-time
collaboration in this fusion example the
fusion device currently runs only for
tens of seconds the next generation of
devices Peter that's being built in
France is expected to run for 300
seconds so uh when the runs after the
runs for that you know it will take a
ten minute break or half an hour break
this is where the operator on-site will
seek advice figure out what to do next
and that's where what we mean by
real-time collaboration because it takes
a few minutes if it if it takes less
than a second then there's no chance for
you to coop your adviser and ask for a
parameter right you have to do it right
there but if it's a few minutes then
there is time to do this type of work of
course you know as a computer person I
deal with files read writes and computer
programs that has to run and the process
is to how to make all of that work
so the the the general approach is to
make the the data management work make
the data go as fast as possible right
that's the basic process and we want the
computer programs that needs to run run
at the right place and for many years
I've been doing work on indexing that
help you to locate the right data record
at the right time and well we'll talk
about feature extraction in this
particular case so as a quick summary in
terms of data management doing the right
thing that's this blue curve you know
can get you a few x in terms of just
time to prepare the data gets data to
the right place and I'll get into more
detail of this a little bit later but
just kind of a quick summary of the the
work we've been doing and in this
particular case if you just you know I
do indexing right so I talk about
indexing if you just do it now evilly
and it actually takes more time than
just copying the files over because
actually building the index takes time
that's where the time is if you do it in
a in a better way that's what this blue
line is here where you use less time so
this is a computer science project we
typically ask you know we're asked to to
try this on different applications
Fusion is one example I don't know how
many of you have read about top marks
there doughnut-shaped devices with hot
plasma in the middle and this hot plasma
are really really hot
they're you know think of mewling
degrees and of course the outside war
are in room you know room temperature
you don't want anything from the
mirroring degree whatever that is to
touch the wall and that's one of the
prongs with this called blob and I guess
the
is kind of indication you know the
physicists haven't exactly figured out
what's the mechanism cost that and what
really they're worried about is this
blob is indication if it if it appears
it indicates the plasma is going to
collapse and it's not going to maintain
its coherence so that's the one that's
the one one thing they are watching out
for the other is it moves around and
it's likely very likely it's going to
hit the wall and it would hit the water
damages a war then you know the device
the wall has to be replaced after that
happened a few times that usually is a
mirroring dollar operation and six
months or nine months of downtime for
the device so that's why their their
interest in this type of work and the
second example that we worked on this
was a supercomputing demo from a couple
years back and this is a material
science simulation they're looking for
fractures cracks in the material as they
grow as this nano structure grow you
know they want they want to figure out
where the cracks will form or how the
cracks were formed and when the crew so
this crack detection is done by this
this group of people is from Georgia
Tech and they were running this
simulation in Singapore and they have
very um the Singapore supercomputer
Center was happy to let them do this
demonstration because they just bought a
cross ocean fiber network and they want
some flashy demonstration so that that's
partly why this was set up but it's a
nice demonstration it does demonstrate a
crack detection and it has a night you
know have a nice show at the
supercomputing floor for people who does
high performance computing
supercomputing is a big big conference
and lots of people go there so it's it's
a high-impact demonstration and this is
a kind of really different from what we
usually be always this is a collaborator
who works in Stony Brook University he
collects medical images he actually
works for medical school over there
this is one of the things that they're
doing is they're collecting tissue
samples and trying to do imaging of the
tissue samples one of the things they
need to do the image is huge hey one of
the things they really really want to do
is to be able to swap patient to you
know get the sample send it to the lab
get the image you know have the patient
wait for five minutes then come back to
say is this is a sample good or there's
cancerous cells in the sample and in
order to do image analysis in a few
minutes they need a pretty quick
turnaround time that's that's where this
comes in and in this particular case the
idea is there will be large computing
facilities somewhere they could make use
of in this particular case they're
actually using an or creature a computer
because part of the collaborators are at
Oakridge they can you know do this image
analysis is a image analysis application
but because the image is large they need
a lot of computing power to to get it
have a quick turnaround and the magic
sauce here is we allow them to to do
this work progressively without reading
for all the image without for all the
images to be collected and without
waiting without putting all the bytes
into files because that takes time - so
just a quick review of what I this work
is about we want to have efficient data
management and we want to be able to
manage the work process you know the
where the computer where the computer
programs run effectively so we can
eventually reduce the time to solution
so that's the quick summary and I
probably should say you know feel free
to ask questions if you have any but
overall that's what I'm trying to get at
I'm going to be talking about data
management process management then you
know some bit of algorithm and
then going back to the fusion example
good Christian yeah
does it since these might be shared
central resources does contention play
any problem playing a role contention
for access to so that's one of the
things we're working on so I guess there
is a consumer computer Center up the
hill from here that we all use the
resource their their work around that
line to to manage that right so the big
supercomputer resources are open batch
scheduled you have to change that policy
you have to make different arrangements
in order to to enable real-time access
the early demonstrations are typically
done with a reserved time slot you know
that that type of setup but in order to
make this much more routine you need
policy in place you need ways to
schedule schedule real time jobs right
that's it what about two let's say just
for the data that you have two different
analysis wanting to work on it at the
same time do you allow for that or is it
usually just one one thing going so far
we're doing you know mostly one task at
a time but the data the data management
engine can recognize you are sharing
data so so for example you have so that
the data in memory data in a way is put
together and as its managed by a demon
and if you have multiple tasks multiple
different analysis that tap to you the
same part or different part of the data
this the central demon could figure
things out and ship you only the data
you need multiple things multiple things
can can talk to the demon at the same
time so that's the part with you know
the data and process management that I'm
gonna go into a bit next
so the core of this data management
system especially is called adios it's a
shorthand for adaptive IO systems but I
think most people just know it as adios
we know that features that we are really
making use of here in this particular
application is it makes it unified state
access you know for remote and local
data access you know you can use the
same interface you you can write a
program you can test the program using
files on your local laptop and the same
program with a few configuration tweaks
you can send to a supercomputer and it
will connect to the right data you don't
have to change your program you just
need to change the configuration
parameters so you will know where to get
the data so if you write you know
typical program you open a file you read
the file those statements those
programming statements in your file in
your program remains the same so that's
what we mean by unifying the local and
remote i/o accesses I unless you're
interested I'm not going to get into the
details but that I think that's the key
point that you don't need to worry about
whether the file is a remote or local if
you use this i/o system the second
feature that's very important that I
already mentioned a little bit is
streaming so you don't have to wait for
the whole file to be written in order to
start processing data in the file this
is the important feature that allow us
to process in case of that big medical
image as soon as a part of the image is
finished
you know generating then that piece of
the image could be analyzed you don't
have to wait for the whole ten gigabyte
image to be generated in order to start
working and that's one way we reduce the
i/o the processing our response time
ah yeah actually there is a illustration
this particular installation is again
from fusion I know it because it has GPI
that's the gas puff imaging the kind of
doesn't matter but that it just helped
me to remind me that this is a real
example so if you if you wait to collect
the data because data collection and
data transfer takes time then you start
analysis that's going to take a to take
a a while in this particular case it
takes about 50 seconds you can you can
break this file transfer into pieces and
then you do analysis piece by piece and
that could help your analysis op to
finish a lot faster right this is a
concept that's it's pretty you know
obvious you can do this and in many
cases this is so the most successful
data management system the MapReduce
system right that that's the commercial
Big Data that one of the big thing they
they are able to do is this data
parallel approach right process one
piece of the data at a time so
effectively this is doing the same thing
processing data or one piece at a time
so question on that in the sense of
typically when when we write out an
image you know we run a checksum on it
just to make sure that we've done it
properly that there were no errors in in
the i/o are is that handled on a chunk
by chunk yes that will be handled in
chunk by chunk basis so so to get into a
little bit detail of what how adios
stores the data REO stores data in
chunks actually most of the i/o systems
file system file format store data in
chunks so the checksum the the local
information like the local statistic
like the mean and max of values they are
there then Nate Chuck's one chunk at a
time
so effectively let allow you to deal
with chunks quite separately from the
rest
Christian yeah you mentioned one of the
top-level concerns having some kind of a
data model and I sort of think of you
know like a sequel query sequel query on
a relational DV yes so things as well
you get that instances that satisfy the
query instance by instance and that
might be an example of so so the
question is how much structure is the
implicit query here based on is it just
a blob that's being delivered so you
know so you mentioned in in you know
qamar most of the commercial data seems
to be following this database approach
write the sequel tables in most of the
scientific data the most common thing is
arrays and I guess our distinguished
interfaces you know high energy
physicist might not agree but in most of
the simulation data and like this one
you data come out as a race if you your
image come to us images could be viewed
as a race a race of pixels right so so
the most the the basic data format arias
use and a number of other you know
common scientific data management system
use of arrays so the the idea of a chunk
would be then a part of an array so you
can think of dividing your array into
bounding box using bounding box grids
right then each piece would be a part of
that so you don't lose the global
context and there's in the enough local
information for you to work on structure
that's the notion of the suit yes so you
can do this you know then stack them
over time yes one other question on the
chunks do the chunks can they overlap so
technically they don't overlap you can
store ghost zones that actually is often
needed in processing but to just to keep
this ideas simple right conceptually
you you do our
a crane division no overlapping that if
you need to if you need to have
boundaries for processing that this can
be taken care of I'm just well okay I'm
just wondering in the case sake say you
have a cancer cell or one of these blobs
yet sort of splits a chunk yes how do
you handle that type of analysis so this
is where you have boundary things right
so so you need to you do need to take
care of the boundaries yes no sampling
involved we so as a computer guy I can't
sample your data for you right if you're
a physicist you say I need this then we
take it literally it means you mean you
need this unless you tell us to a random
sample we don't read it to a random
sample we with if you say find places
where it's plasma right we're talking
about hot plasma blobs typically means
it's hotter than than the rest so will
you tell us what's the definition of
hotter right so you say for example we
know exactly what is the temperature
would be hot or what is the momentum
that you want to look for so we will we
will look for those exactly
and that actually sometime creates a
challenges because for example Google
can can bend those rules you say I look
forward I look for supernovae you know
type supernova in Google search box
Google has no guarantee that they will
return you or the order document
mentioning supernovae right but so so we
we try to well the design for in our
work is to say if you say you want
search for supernovae well China will
find all the supernovae mentioning
instances - you know no sampling
I see inside an audio system is a
transport engine that allows us to work
on remote machines so I just in case
this might be unfamiliar when W a in
here's is for wide area network so we're
talking about you know data that's
generating in South Korea that's used in
Georgia you know at Georgia Tech then
gets sent to Denver for display that
that sort of distributed processing okay
and there are liberal pieces in there we
have indexing we have compression then
we have other transformations to ensure
the data only the peony the pieces that
you need get to you and try not to bring
that more than necessary this repeats
some of the same idea so I'm gonna stay
skip this and that's gets into more
technical details I don't know how many
people are interested so just to show
that there there is actual software
behind this that you know somebody needs
to write so in remember we were talking
about just getting the interesting data
okay so let's say that the the red means
high temperature the gray part are the
relatively low temperature they will now
be shipped so the so the other idea
that's shown here is the data gets
divided so into chunks and only the
chunks that to have relatively high
temperature ones in then needs to be
moved so this is where the indexing
coming in and the the the blocking of
the data it's helpful that you know
reducing the data movement is helping us
to reduce the turnaround time in this
process and this is a relatively small
image so we're not we can't get too much
gain out of this because
it's relatively small but you imagine if
you have a much larger thing you're
looking for is relatively small piece
you can get a lot of gain by doing this
indexing so the other process that we I
mentioned is try to figure out where is
the most appropriate place to run this
type of analysis jobs and this this
slide is talking about that you know you
have a workflow that might take a few
steps and we have a system that will you
know allow us to place the jobs in the
right way to minimize the data movement
and minimize the turnaround time
so that's a quick rundown I expect you
know we don't have too many computer
science in the audience I'm not getting
into a lot of detail in there so maybe
the feature extraction algorithm could
be slightly more interesting so I'm
gonna talk about the feature extraction
algorithm so it right here so this on
this diagram on the left is a basic
process you know we we get the data we
we find cells that are hot whatever the
definition would be and then we
effectively group those cells into
regions and this does touch on the part
so this part requires the so this part
are all data parallel or embarrassingly
parallel depending on which term you're
more familiar with so this part requires
coordination that what Peter was
mentioning if you have a region that's
on the boundary of when when chunk and
you need to be connected to another
chunk that's that's why that's this one
that requires pro valuation the
paralyzation we're doing a text Vantage
of both distributed parallel that's MPI
programs as well as shredding so as well
as openmp so you can imagine and you
know multiple shredding helps in this
process because we we need some amount
of processing in this particular step so
I've not let me see how oh yes I'm going
to actually jumping into so that the
data the data parallel part you know
whatever the condition is we evaluate
the condition the user gave us that's
the reason what is straightforward what
I'm going to do is next is going to
explain a little bit about the details
of how to do this step that requires
parallel and requires us to to merge the
point
Solutions into regions of interest so
the blob is supposed to be a region in
this in this talk mark so just just just
to kind of reiterate you know the the
conditions we evaluate a reasonably
straightforward like this basic stress
holding we can handle arithmetic
operations you know that type of
conditions we get point solutions then
the next so then then the next is to
connect the points in two regions that's
what this step is and that's where we
need some parallelization there is one
point that's interesting here is this
maybe is getting into the nitty-gritty
here so if you're so if if they're if
the region you select have say so n is a
total number of points in your data set
and the the volume that you select is V
and what what is interesting is we have
an algorithm that can process all this
that's proportional to the surface of
the volume rather than actually the
volume and this is partly because we
compress we compress the index of the
data we so this is doesn't even
involving compressing the data itself
but because we're processing orders in
index using the index so as well as the
index is compressed we can achieve this
pretty nice property so if you're
interested we get we can get into more
of that detail but I think our skip on
that the details and mentioning a little
bit more about connected component
labeling that's the technique that we
use to connect the points in two regions
in space
identifying patches yes we have a faster
what we have felt with so actually we we
identity so in most of the storage
schemes you need to linearize your data
points you know that comes from 3d into
some into some linear form right we take
we try to take advantage of this
linearization so in many of the physics
things or physical things nearby nearby
things have similar values right so it's
kind of easy to understand it's because
they're nearby physically they have
similar values therefore they are easy
to compress put together and that's what
we're taking advantage of sorry once
once you've done your threshold light
you see you then and have to coalesce
things in yes so so you know nearby
things have similar values so we can we
can quickly coalesce after we've done so
that part of that it use is encoded in
this index right so so so this Peter
knows I talked about fast fit a lot so
part of this is fast bit has this
compression scheme that naturally take
advantage of this property that nearby
values are similar therefore they can be
coalesced in this indexing
representation so this so we after we do
that so what we can end up is we have a
bunch of line segment that's from your
mesh representing the space or from line
segment from an image that representing
things that you're interested in the
next step is to connect those nine
segments into into regions okay so this
is what talking about the data structure
that we use how to get to that and
there's crazy names
like scan with array-based union-find we
can talk about that in detail if you
like but they're there algorithms that
allow you to do this reasonably fast so
the in this process you might think the
the easy the straightforward way is to
keep a list you know add to the list you
know those sort of techniques it turns
out that just apply assigning labels to
this line segment is the better way to
go and this actually has a long history
of research work in this and that's what
this that's that's why this algorithm is
called connected component labeling so
you label the component rather than
actually trying to develop a data
structure that put things together so
putting things together requires dynamic
memory allocation moving pointers around
that that's expensive just assign labels
you'll need to change a number and
that's easy okay so that I think you
know in a very high level but that's
what's going on that's why this is
connected component labeling not kinetic
component collection or some other term
so this is a bit more detail of how well
this works lots of you know tests and
saying this works well I think unless
you're really interesting the details
are also just say the so there is this
idea of number of nine segments the
query lines that's that's the idea we
versus the number of points
so getting the algorithm to scale
proportional to number of lines is is
the goal here there are some there's
some theoretical proof that says the
connected component labeling algorithm
in the worst case is super linear and so
so we're trying to say in reality it's
actually linear
that's getting a little bit too
technical oh yeah this is the
illustration of the lines so we're
dealing with Taurus so we're not dealing
with straight forward line so we're
actually dealing lines that are so calls
well they're not even actually so cause
they're there
distorted circles but this is the
illustration the line we're talking
about our stretches like this okay and
the entry the the regions that get found
through this process are those this type
of long skinny shapes in Taurus because
plasma are moving in in the in the
Taurus in this direction so so most of
the features have that look to it
where we can do this labeling fast
that's not too surprising so we're
talking about the plasma physics how to
find those fusion blots and what this
shows is the this parallel algorithm
scales reason scales quite well hey so
this this is a strong skelling of course
we need to start with a larger problem
so just in case you're reading the
labels on one process this is used this
is a slightly smaller this is a weak
scaling this is strong scaling we need
to start with a slightly larger problem
but in general it scales quite well one
important thing we're very happy with is
we're able to get this down to about you
know a couple a couple milliseconds
that's that's that's a good goal to
achieve because this particular imaging
device well I guess I haven't mentioned
this yet this particular image device is
operating at something like a couple of
milliseconds you know it takes a picture
every couple of minutes second if we
want to keep up we need to have a
turnaround time that's not bigger than
that okay so it works so that point is
to show it works well in parallel and
you know we can actually get it as fast
as the image device could operate
so I'm gonna go back to talk about the
fusion examples a bit more and so this
may be a time for me to post a little
bit just in case you're interested in
the connected component labeling and
paralyzation techniques just a question
for so taking so I assume this was on
the current one of the current devices
are they getting faster or larger in the
next general so they're getting they're
getting larger
so getting slightly getting the larger
image is not a problem the problem is in
this particular fusion example they're
they're getting the image the number of
pixels of that imaging device is
increasing but it's not increasing to be
a problem because they're they're still
only talking about a couple hundred by a
couple hundred per image but the the
rate it's taking the picture that's
challenging to a to a lot of processing
algorithms I like that and the medical
imaging example where they they take
very high-resolution image they scan but
they scan one little piece of you know
your your your sample at a time right so
that's why we can do can do the same
pieces this one is a relatively small
image but fairly high frequency yeah in
terms of some assuming that the labeling
process is there structure on the label
or is that is there relabeling that goes
on as as the coalescence or is there a
sort of a data some metadata structure
on the labels that grow so indicate the
coalescing
to keep things simple we we use integer
labels and when when two things that
were initially labeled differently and
later found to should have the same
label the the smaller label is always
used that is important because that
simplifies the logic of programming
because if you have to make complicated
decisions like how many have you know
say you say you decided you want to keep
the label that that has more element
right then you have to go examine and
you know all the elements and count how
many the decision of always use a
smaller label is a much easier thing
because you can just look at the two
numbers and take the smaller one right
so so there there are a couple of simple
tricks like this to simplify the process
but there no no say global criteria
about the number of connected the number
of regions no because however many
connected regions you you find is the
connected regions you find right it's
yes so it's driven by the data of course
there there are criterias like if you
find a region that only have two cells
you you drop it because it's too small
it's not interesting right there there
may be criteria like that but that comes
later
so we label to everything first you know
in this data is you can imagine the
camera is pretty noisy right if you get
one pixel something it's probably not
interesting so that but that comes later
we don't deal with that in the labeling
process so in the labeling process we
just want to want to go as fast as we
can
so here's a bit more detail about that
fusion example so there this is this is
a experimental data the simulation data
could have a much larger volume and
could generate a lot more it could be
more troublesome if they want because
this simulation is a particle yourself
simulation which means they track
particles through magnetic field and
they they open can can stress the
supercomputers just by putting in more
more particles and I we have worked with
people who put you know ten trolling
particles in their simulation the the
one one time when slapshot of that would
be hundreds of terabytes so they could
definitely the simulations could
definitely stretch any machine but this
is a more talking about the experiment
and the other interesting thing that
we're working on is if if you see a
particular behavior in the experiment
how quickly can you either look up
similar features in the simulation or
spun up a simulation that could have
similar conditions that can tell you how
frequently is that particular feature
you know happening so so there's inter
comparisons that you know it's it's even
more challenging so the the fusion
plasma looks like this the jacket age
comes out because the this is actually
it's actually torus right we there are
cells that we don't care that they're
not they're not drawn and the age that
the edge well there's triangulated
device that's why you see triangles at
the edge it's not a mistake it's just
that data outside that we with
tract of you can imagine the red part
are the blobs and the white dots in here
I'm not sure whether it's visible to you
those are the points that we initially
identify that are that has the
conditions that we like so the regions
are outlined with this red line and
that's after you do this connected
component labeling and identify those
regions one of the important tasks is
this is def this is a different part
from a different slapshot of a same time
step because it's a torus right so we're
looking at four different cross sections
of this and one of the things that is
interesting is remember we're talking
about we don't want this plasma to hit
the wall and that means we need to track
we need to track those blobs and see how
how much they are moving and then
predict whether the movement is going to
anticipate to take this particular block
to the wall that's the next step that in
this process
excuse me in the cross sections where is
the wall ah so the war is though so the
war is out here so if you look at this
image the war is out here so we're now
simulating the wall we're simulating
inside the wall where the where the hot
plasma is so the war is is is out here
okay we're looking this is you've sliced
the doughnut so if it was slice the
doughnut yes so we're looking at the one
circle you know this small circle and
actually we're looking only at I have a
good way to get to the whole doughnut
picture oh that's wait that's all right
let me go all the way back so you know
no it's alright it's good to explain
this I think I have time I don't have
too many more slides so what we are
really simulating is is near here near
the near the the outside because really
close to the center of the circle
nothing interesting happens well well if
something happens there it will take a
long time for it to propagate to outside
so what is really critical is look at
almost next to the edge so what that
picture shown you is ah
so this is a good example so there is a
black line here that's called separatrix
so the the critical part Weir's we're
simulating is fairly close to the
separatrix and so you can see this black
line here so this is the plasma
developing if the plasma is developing
and it's moving outside that is that's
that's troublesome
so
so we need to so effectively what we're
doing after we that do the connected
component labeling we can gather all the
cells together then we can figure out
where is the center then we can track
how the center R is moving and based on
the trajectory then we can do some
simple predictions
so the predictions you know that we're
doing right now it's really simple
definitely has to be verified by the
physicists we can claim we're doing that
part in any meaningful way just yet so
this is a big this effort involves a
number of people and this is so this is
the actual physical actual image from
from the physical device this is a kind
of a schematic diagram of how this is
being processed and the data comes from
K star they so it's a fusion it's a it's
a first it's the first fully
superconducting tokamak and so the
Korean South Korean government involved
you know invested quite a lot of money
in this kisti is their data center so a
lot of processing happens at case T and
the the movie like this are produced by
you know collaborators past tech is
Korean University of course PPP L is one
of the premier Institute involved in
plasma physics that we work with they
help us with this
ah so this is an illustration of so this
is the illustration of the the inter
comparison between Rio the experimental
image which is shown to the left and the
simulation image and you can see you
know generally they they they go up and
down which means they're there in this
in the radio direction they're not
moving towards toward the wall and the
distribution of the the radio movement
is about the same and so that they're
they're able to replicate simulation of
real experiment to to the extent where
the radio velocity distribution is about
the same and we can this this so this
obviously has can be typically this can
be run a lot faster because this
involves a lot larger data takes a bit
more time to do and we're working on
techniques that allow them to be done at
the same time
so just as just as a summary we're
dealing with a lot of data to get to to
get to the data quickly one of the
central things that we're doing is to
organize data correctly and index data
when the data is generated because often
because the process of generating the
index open is expensive and people don't
want to take the or of the data back out
again just to generate the index so
generating index right when the data is
generated is important so there were you
know understanding the trade-offs
between how fast we can process and how
much data we can get in in that that is
another part of the study reduce the
value of the data by you know having
this index tell tell you where the data
is you know that's one way to reduce the
data the of course also there's
compression adiós is introducing
compression and we are also working on
different ways to do compression one of
the things that's actually quite
interesting is we're developing a
statistics based compression technique
that actually you know works quite well
in situations like this where you have
intrinsically there are a certain amount
of randomness in the data that
statistical feature extraction can work
for compression
I guess ultimately you know this work is
to demonstrate we have computer science
techniques that enable scientists to do
distributed data analysis in near
real-time yeah so the diffusion example
is what I talked here and you know other
people I mentioned you know talk to have
medical image and have other things that
are using this line of technique as well
so that's what I have and here the name
of the author's involved and even the
URL to the paper and there's my email
and this is my research groups website
if you're interested Thanks
[Applause]
we have time for a few more questions
so Don I wanted to revisit one of the
topics that was sort of already
discussed in the questions that was the
matching between the streaming buffer
sizes and sort of what one might call
the analyzable chunks that occur in the
data so you know you said that you have
to take care of the events but or the
edges but if you've got a indexed file
on disk you can actually you know count
it and every index points to something
right but if you've got index it comes
up you know in the early part of the
metadata for a data streaming and you
know my point today that was will be
coming later how do you I mean are there
techniques that are sort of generic or
recurring that allow you to sort of
match the analysis chunks with the
buffer sizes that are coming through so
far we have been dealing with relatively
straightforward cases that we know how
to deal with I'm you might be thinking
of some cases that probably require a
bit more thinking so
so one of the things that that is that
is always necessary
you know you need certain amount of
metadata right so so those metadata you
cannot skip on that so some of this
processing like only sending the
interesting pieces from the data source
to the analysis engine that means the
Summum some amount of the filtering need
information needs to pass from the
analysis engine to the center right so
you so you can do the filtering at the
sauce so for example if you want only
the data with temperature between 800
and 1000 then that that filter needs to
be sent to the the sauce right because
otherwise the sauce has no no no choice
but to send you everything so so that's
this is this is this view is kind of
flange right you you for example you
could be talking about you only one time
step five and ten and you don't care
about any time steps in between that
type of your information also needs to
be to be sent to the to the sauce so
this so the data source could be aware
of this and not blindly trying to send
you all the time steps
the question on the compression that
you're looking at is it lossy or
lossless its lossy so yes I we're aware
some other people might not like lossy
compression yes yeah yeah okay but you
just tuned it to the level at which the
scientists can deal with it yeah so that
that's one way to make it work so you
you can so this is this is this is a new
work more recent work any other
questions
all right let's thank John
[Applause]